un año ha pasado desde que las tropas
rusas incursionaron en el territorio
ucraniano dando inicio a una operación
militar especial como lo han denominado
desde el kremlin a los ojos de los
ucranianos de los europeos de Estados
Unidos y también de buena parte de la
comunidad internacional simplemente se
trataba de una invasión el conflicto en
el don vass abierto desde el año 2014
escaló a otras dimensiones desde
entonces millones de ucranianos han
abandonado su país miles de rusos y
ucranianos también han perdido la vida
en ambos lados del frente de guerra y
cientos de ciudades y poblaciones han
sido completamente arrasadas por las
operaciones militares la guerra volvió
entonces a tocar las puertas de Europa
de la forma más cruda que nos podíamos
haber imaginado hoy cuando ya se cumple
un año de haber iniciado esta invasión
los aliados de Ucrania apuestan por
armar aún más a las tropas ucranianas
dotándolas con tanques equipos militares
de Última Generación y armas mientras
que Rusia ha reforzado sus tropas ha
desplegado más equipos y de tanto en
tanto le recuerda a la comunidad
internacional que es una potencia
nuclear de Gran calibre lo que ninguna
de las dos partes en este momento está
planteando es la posibilidad de dialogar
para buscar un acuerdo y el fin de la
guerra lo que nos dice que este
conflicto puede prolongarse en el tiempo
cómo llegó el mundo a este escenario a
esta guerra ya ha pasado un año y que
sigue entonces para Ucrania para Rusia
para las partes involucradas es decir
Estados Unidos la Unión Europea los
países de la otan China y los países
vecinos de este conflicto la
continuación de la guerra Qué precio
tiene entonces para la comunidad
internacional y para la humanidad entera
porque ya vimos que el alcance es a
escala mundial hoy en el debate de
France 24 Ucrania a un año del inicio de
la invasión de Rusia
[Música]
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
Hugo facio él es historiador y doctor en
ciencia política es autor del libro
Rusia y Ucrania una guerra es también
profesor titular de la Universidad de
los Andes en Bogotá en Colombia también
está con nosotros Gonzalo Fiore viani él
es magíster en relaciones
internacionales y es becario del conicet
en Argentina Le recuerdo que ustedes
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte de este debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales en Twitter en
Facebook y en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f-24
todo junto todo pegado y a mí me
encuentran en Twitter con mi cuenta
personal arroba santilogo no olviden
también que todos los contenidos de este
programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Hugo Hugo Gracias por estar con
nosotros en el debate de France 24 y un
año de haber iniciado esta invasión de
las tropas rusas al territorio ucraniano
qué balance hace usted qué nos deja este
año de guerra y conflicto que ha
escalado allí en el este de Europa Mira
bueno Muchas gracias por esta invitación
la verdad que es un placer estar aquí
con usted y poder compartir algunas
reflexiones sobre lo que ha ocurrido en
Rusia en Ucrania la verdad es que hacer
un balance del año no resulta tan fácil
porque sin duda teníamos algunas
expectativas teníamos esperanza de
lactosa pudiese la verdad que acabar de
manera mucho más temprana pero la verdad
que llevamos un año de conflicto el año
pasado muy rápido han ocurrido muchas
cosas y la verdad es que todo Deja
entrever de que el conflicto todavía
tiene un tiempo más para proseguir creo
que las últimas declaraciones hechas por
Putin de que Rusia no va a perder la
guerra o la de biden de que Ucrania
tampoco va a perder la guerra presagia
de que esto va tiende a durar es decir
No hay ninguna voluntad de negociación
de las partes ni de ceder un ápice en
ninguno de los en ninguno de los
sentidos por lo tanto creo que tenemos
un escenario complejo de escalamiento
del conflicto y la verdad que este
escalamiento del conflicto va de menos a
más decir cada vez se están utilizando
armas de mayor alcance eso puede llegar
algún momento en que alguna de las
partes y cuando digo algunas partes
sobre todo el caso de Rusia se sienta ya
que como tal que está amenazada en su
integridad misma y decida también seguir
aumentando el escalamiento del conflicto
no Entonces por ese lado la cosa creo
que tiende a complicarse no hay mucha
voluntad de grandes actores y en eso
creo que hay algo que puede jugar un
papel muy importante y es el resto del
mundo es decir yo no creo que en los
países europeos occidentales como lo
llamamos muchas veces estén en
condiciones de
avanzar hacia un escenario de paz y
obviamente Rusia tampoco y en ese
sentido creo que los países llamados a
veces del sur
pueden convertirse en actores que tienen
mucho interés en poner fin a este
conflictores más adelante Hugo vamos a
estar analizando justamente esa posición
que pueden tener esos países del sur y
también la región de América Latina en
este conflicto que ha sido bastante
tímida a la hora de expresar algún tipo
de opinión o no decir que han tenido que
tomar algún tipo de parte en el
conflicto pero sí por lo menos Mostrar
algún tipo de ayuda o algún tipo de
posicionamiento frente a la situación o
por lo menos las consecuencias hablo a
escala humanitaria tan complicado este
conflicto por la cantidad de gente que
ha tenido que abandonar Ucrania le doy
ahora paso a Gonzalo para conocer la
opinión el mismo Punto de partida
Gonzalo Bienvenido al programa Gracias
por estar con nosotros y un año de la
guerra en Ucrania un año del inicio de
esta invasión de tropas rusas al
territorio del este de Ucrania y del sur
de ese país también Cuál es el balance
que usted hace bien antes que nada
Muchas gracias por por la invitación
participar Este programa y un saludo a
toda la audiencia del programa y del
Canal respecto de del balance del año de
lo que está pasando bueno por un lado
coincido coincido con el colega creo que
vamos hacia un conflicto por lo menos
que se va a extender en el mediano plazo
si es que no también en el largo plazo
cuando se dio la invasión a Ucrania
voces de la inteligencia de los Estados
Unidos decían que Ucrania podía llegar a
caer 72 horas bueno Esto claramente no
pasó por una serie diversa de factores
no por un lado el apoyo occidental el
esposo de los países de de la otan que
está siendo importantísimo en sostener a
Ucrania Más allá de las sanciones
económicas y del aislamiento El que se
está intentando
someter a Rusia Más allá de eso la ayuda
militar
económica a Ucrania es fundamental en
este sentido y retomando un poco lo que
lo que decía el colega previamente
respecto de la la el punto muerto en el
que se encuentran hoy las negociaciones
de paz un dato interesante es que en la
última semana en esta gira que estuvo
haciendo y que se reunió con el Primer
Ministro británico que se pone Manuel
macron en Francia que se reunió con Joe
biden el mismo Ucrania lo que está
repitiendo
es que no hay diálogo posible con Rusia
y que no se le puede creer nada al
kremlin no Entonces en ese sentido se
inhabilita cualquier tipo de de
negociación de paz desde su lado y por
también útil desde Rusia y habilita
cualquier tipo de negociación de paz
cuando dice que va a ganar el conflicto
y que el territorio que está reclamando
le pertenece a Rusia Entonces no hay
diálogo ni terreno común posible y eso
es realmente algo muy preocupante para
pensar el mediano plazo porque Durante
este año hubo algunas pequeñas
instancias recuerdo una mediación de
algún momento pequeñas atisbos de de
negociaciones que finalmente por
supuesto Lamentablemente
Gonzalo continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa en el debate y en el
análisis y quiero que recordemos un año
después de haber iniciado esta invasión
de tropas rusas al territorio de Ucrania
cuáles fueron esos factores o esas
alarmas que la comunidad internacional
no le prestó atención que evidenciaban
que rusa Rusia en algún momento iba a
invadir el territorio del Don vast había
un conflicto ya abierto desde el año
2014 ya era una constante entre kiev y
entre Moscú Pero en qué momento esto se
convirtió en una guerra a escala
internacional que justamente la
comunidad internacional Tal parece que
no vio venir Putin dio algunas alarmas
dijo que se sentía amenazado el mundo
occidental tal vez no le prestó atención
qué análisis hace y totalmente bueno en
esto
demasiado originalidad creo que
pensador internacional de Estados Unidos
tiene mucha razón él lo advirtió en su
momento
volvió a decirlo el año pasado previo el
comienzo de la guerra y durante la
Guerra también lo que había dicho que si
seguimos si occidente seguía aislando
Rusia sí la otan seguía avanzando cada
vez más al este no rompiendo de alguna
manera esa promesa que le había hecho
Bush padre a gorbacho en en 1990 ni un
centímetro más al este nos vamos a
extender Como lotan si eso seguía
sucediendo con Rusia de alguna manera se
iba a sentir acorralado de alguna manera
iba a sentir que se estaba extendiendo
occidente hacia su territorio e iba a
reaccionar no por supuesto
Lamentablemente reaccionó desde la
manera que uno esperaba que podía ser
regional que violentamente mediante la
invasión y mediante la profundización de
un conflicto que ya se viene sucediendo
como bien decía desde 2014 pero creo que
fueron varios momentos durante estos
años que se fue viendo de alguna manera
que algo así podía suceder biden durante
la campaña permanentemente prometida la
expansión de la otan hacia Ucrania
Ucrania posteriormente
al a la revolución de colores y
recuerdan bien el euro maidan y todo
esto también se hablaba de un
acercamiento cada vez mayor a occidente
y un rechazo cada vez mayor a Rusia y a
todo lo que esto representaba Entonces
se fue dando esta composición de
factores y Hugo Cuál es su opinión estas
alertas que no vimos en la comunidad
internacional esto era previsible O
evitable tal vez es la palabra correcta
sí Mira yo creo que hay una dificultad
cuando uno analiza este conflicto Es que
este conflicto en el fondo tiene varios
estratos de conflictividad no es una
guerra unidimensional que solamente
ataña a unos actores una lógica del
conflicto y que por lo tanto la solución
pueda ubicarse solo en un plano en
alguna medida uno puede decir aquí hay
un conflicto que ya viene latente que
tiene mucho que ver con lo que es la la
el desmonte de lo que fue la implosión
de lo que fue la unión soviética en
alguna medida todos pensamos y yo que
soy experto en temas ruso escribí mucho
Sobre esos temas años atrás siempre
pensamos que había implosionado la unión
soviética que se había acabado un
imperio y se acabó y la verdad que tal
vez estos conflictos y está todas estas
cosas que se ha sucedido en el espacio
la antigua soviético dar a entender de
que en el fondo la implosión de la unión
de La Unión soviética El del imperio ha
sido un poquito más lenta y en ese
sentido hay muchas cosas que todavía no
están arregladas esa caída del Imperio y
que quedaron un poco en standby que un
standby en alguna medida el tema de
crimea que un standby en el fondo para
los rusos Cuáles eran las reales
fronteras de Rusia porque para muchos
rusos yo no conecto no los quiero
justificar para ellos
en la unión soviética era Rusia tanto
todos esos territorios le pertenecería
Entonces con eso digo es una voz muy
importante y existe Entonces ese es un
tipo de conflictividad después se ha
venido dando situaciones
en torno al Don vass y en ese sentido
han habido dos cosas sin duda una
concentración
soldados rusos
desde el tiempo atrás antes de la
inflación Pero también es una alta
concentración de soldados subrayanos en
la frontera en dolpás y presagiaban a
atacar el don por lo tanto aquí hay otro
nivel de conectividad que nosotros no
podemos pasar con
y En tercer lugar está todo el tema ya
más internacional que tiene que ver con
el tema de la seguridad europea que la
seguridad europea siempre quedó en
veremos después de la desintegración de
La Unión soviética del desmonte del
Pacto de Varsovia
y la otan que un poco perdió su Norte
siguió existiendo se siguió ampliando en
ese sentido ahí hay un tema que tiene
que ver que quedó y resuelto el tema de
la seguridad Europea
y es así tema permanente de Hugo
entendiendo entonces lo que usted nos
dice en este comentario por qué esta
guerra es diferente para Rusia vimos al
ejército y a las fuerzas militares al
gobierno de este país en otros
conflictos Como por ejemplo el de
chechenia que era visto desde la
comunidad internacional como un problema
interno con una República rusa al
interior de del país el conflicto con
Georgia que pues era un país que no no
genera tanta controversia a nivel
internacional como lo puede generar
Ucrania que está más del lado europeo
Georgia está en el lado del cáucaso
culturalmente además es muy distinto a
Rusia y también hay una historia
cultural en común entre Ucrania y Rusia
que tal vez a Moscú Georgia no le
resulta tan atractivo como si le resulta
atractiva la historia en común que hay
con kiev porque entonces este este
conflicto es diferente porque se ve de
una manera distinta
a ver yo creo que se debe leer de una
manera distinta porque inclusive lo que
es Ucrania hoy en día tenemos que
entenderlo esta morfología que tiene el
país tiene una serie de de de de de de
de de de de condiciones que lo hacen muy
sugieres Mira te necesito solamente un
dato la dejar la expresión que está al
oeste de Ucrania ha tenido más de 300
años de relaciones estrecha con Rusia
perteneciendo a la Unión soviética o lo
que sea pero muy cercano en cambio tú
miras el Dif oleópolis como se le dice
en español resulta que solamente hizo
estuvo cercanía con Rusia durante 50
años de la época después del año 39 o 45
cuando la unión soviética es este
territorio O sea hay una parte de
ucracia que sin duda ha sido muy lejano
muy lejano a Rusia a la cultura rusa al
ortodoxia y demás Pero hay otra parte
oriental que ha tenido una estrecha
relación por tanto es un país que tiene
una morfología muy compleja porque tiene
unas partes que están muy occidentales
sin duda y se sienten occidentales
y hoy día creo que son los que están
tomando la iniciativa política y una
parte oriental llena de población o rusa
o antigua descendientes de ruso porque
aplicaciones en menos con Rusia Entonces
es una cosa compleja Claro ya lo digo la
misma Tania con eso vuelvo y lo repito
no se trata de justificar con esto la el
tema de la anexión pero sin Mostrar la
complejidad que tiene este conflicto
claro Ahora hay una dimensión de este
conflicto Perdón que me extiendo un
poquito y es que este es un conflicto
que
ha ido poco a poco generando réplicas en
otros ámbitos y hoy día podemos decir
que es una guerra bastante sui generis
en el sentido que es una guerra mundial
es una guerra que ha ido extendiéndose
en diferentes ámbitos por todo
financiero comercial energético y demás
Eso hace que ya ni siquiera es un
conflicto netamente ruso craneal Sí y lo
vemos a la escala internacional por
ejemplo con la venta de los cereales a
nivel internacional la repercusiones que
ha tenido y también la propaganda que ha
habido del lado y lado lo vamos a
analizar en unos minutos Gonzalo regreso
con usted para hacerle una pregunta
también de balance del año y es Cuando
comenzó esta invasión
dentro de todas las preguntas que se le
hacía al gobierno ruso era las las
causas y por qué habían llegado a este
escenario de invadir el este de Ucrania
y una de las razones que daba el
presidente Putin era que necesitaban
provocar un nuevo orden mundial hoy un
año después ustedes pueden entender cuál
es esa propuesta de orden mundial que ve
el presidente Putin en necesidad para
para establecer en en la comunidad
internacional porque lo que vemos ahora
es un país agresor un país que está
siendo sancionado por la comunidad
internacional aislado en muchísimos
escenarios Cuál es ese esa concepción de
mundo que tiene el presidente Putin y
bueno Por ende el gobierno ruso
Bueno creo que la concepción punto que
tiene
donde el poder donde el eje del poder
global se traslade de occidente a
Oriente No es cierto en la posguerra en
la primero posterior a la Segunda Guerra
Mundial cuando durante la Guerra Fría
con las instituciones occidentales
occidentales impuestas por los Estados
Unidos etcétera y después en la Guerra
Fría sobre todo hubo ya una hegemonía
después del mundo Bipolar hubo una
hegemonía de los Estados Unidos muy
clara No es cierto que la podríamos
ejercer
autores dicen los otros dicen quiere el
ascenso de China etcétera etcétera hoy
tenemos un mundo multipolar con
distintos con distintos polos como dice
la palabra con distintos países que de
alguna manera están disputando el
liderazgo el escenario internacional
pero todo china sobre todo los Estados
Unidos también países como India
inclusive países como Brasil de alguna
manera más acá en América Latina y por
supuesto Rusia no más de esto creo que
lo que tiene Putin en la cabeza
directamente es una reformulación de las
instituciones internacionales de los
organismos internacionales
creados impulsados por los Estados
Unidos que por ejemplo china no tiene
China si uno ve su accional a lo largo
de El Siglo 21 donde empieza a tener
otro rol internacional a partir de 2008
incluso más atrás a partir del 99 2000
cuando ingresa la organización mundial
de comercio china ingresa a los
organismos internacionales y a las
instituciones internacionales ya
establecidas para
de alguna manera beneficiarse y para
intentar moldearlas en su propio
beneficio sin cuestionar su propio
funcionamiento no en cambio Rusia lo que
está mostrando a partir sobre todo de la
invasión a Ucrania del año pasado es que
directamente quiere reformular
absolutamente todo no Ahora hay que ver
qué Aliado encontrar en esto habla mucho
en los últimos en las últimas semanas
traigo la oficina a colación porque
biden el mismo y dijo que china puede
llegar a apoyar a Rusia con armamento o
de manera económica a su a su ejército o
con ayudas militares varias y claro
esto de ninguna manera va a ser así pero
en la internacional se está hablando
cada vez más de esto yo creo que la
visión de orden internacional que hoy
tiene en Rusia y que hoy tiene China son
muy diferentes por más que unos
geopolíticamente los pueda llegar a
poner de alguna manera más o menos claro
y Hugo qué piensa usted
Mira yo estoy de acuerdo con lo que con
los recientemente señalado en el sentido
de que Rusia y China son tan juntos hoy
en día pero no es una alianza Inclusive
tienen diferencias grandes porque en el
fondo una cosa que se está ocurriendo en
el mundo
dar lugar a pensar no es decir en los
países Europa y también Estados Unidos
tiene una visión de lo internacional que
es conformar campos de actuación de un
conjunto de Estados para operar entonces
ahí tenemos en la Unión Europea tenemos
la otan tenemos la Unión o el
estrechamiento relaciones entre Estados
Unidos y occidente en cambio lo que
vemos en los países asiáticos y lo vemos
también en Rusia lo vemos en otros lados
son unas alianzas la verdad que bastante
particulares y pueden ser a veces muy
fortuitas en temas puntuales y
desaveniencias en otra entonces podemos
encontrar una Turquía con Rusia que se
entienden algunas cosas pero son
totalmente distintos en otro inclusive o
jueves entonces en alguna en otra
posición entonces creo que eso es una
cosa dinámica una nueva dinámica estando
en el mundo en el fondo son alianzas un
poco por conveniencia
y que pueden ser muy estrecha pero
particular ahora bien creo que hay una
visión que tiene Putin y Putin tiene una
visión oligárquica del sistema
internacional es decir es lo que siente
este occidente no le ha dado el juego
parece que se merece que Rusia es un
país
tiene que ser uno de los grandes actores
del sistema mundial y hay que
reconocerle ese error ese rol y claro
cuando personas como Obama dijo una
oración de Rusia no era más que una
potencia media eso los rusos les duele
terriblemente ellos consideran que sí
son tan potencia del mundo si está a
Rusia se le diera ese rol ellos sin duda
lo cumplen y no creo que estén tan en
contra las instituciones que hoy existen
ellos no van a cesárea supuesto en
Naciones Unidas al contrario eso es lo
que les gusta él como es como un país
poderoso poder decidir cosas y si hay
algo que ellos no aceptan es que un país
pequeño Ucrania te vaya a decidir a
ellos
esa es su visión
Sí y eso está todavía Esa visión de
mundo todavía en construcción porque
este conflicto sigue y esto
desencadenara un nuevo orden mundial y
ese orden mundial creo que ha comenzado
una construcción ya desde hace varios
años atrás tal vez ustedes coinciden o
no en esta apreciación Pero yo lo digo
partiendo de la base en que la
diplomacia por ejemplo en este conflicto
no ha tenido espacio vemos y lo
mencionaba yo al principio del programa
y usted lo mencionaron también a las dos
partes rápidamente tratando de mejorar
su capacidad militar pidiendo ayuda a la
comunidad internacional tratando de
fortalecerse para enfrentar una posible
gran escalada que va a llegar en la
primavera en solamente en una cuestión
de semanas aquí Tal parece que el
diálogo la diplomacia y grandes garantes
de la diplomacia a nivel internacional
como se hacía ver la Unión Europea en su
momento y unos organismos
internacionales no han podido surtir
efecto acá Hugo qué análisis si usted de
esa pérdida de la Democracia no hay
diálogo en este conflicto por lo menos
hasta ahora sí con respecto al tema de
la Democracia no de la diplomacia perdón
y vemos al presidente biden diciendo que
esto es una guerra entre demócratas
frente
autoritarios eso no es cierto yo creo
que esa es una vulgarización de la de la
vida internacional el mundo de mucho más
complejo de eso pero mi tesis la voy a
plantear un poco perspectiva yo creo que
hay algo interesante que ocurrió con la
pandemia nos olvidamos y creemos que la
pandemia ocurrió hace mucho tiempo atrás
y la verdad que fue bastante reciente en
el fondo de la pandemia Sí fue un gran
llamado de atención en el mundo de que
había muchas cosas que tenían que
cambiar
y entre esas cosas que tenían que
cambiar es en el fondo ir girando el
mundo de un orden geopolítico basado en
la soberanías y demás a un mundo que
resuelva los grandes problemas de las
sociedades del mundo de hoy y son los
problemas medioambientales los problemas
de la desigualdad los temas de la
pobreza una serie de temas de otra
naturaleza lo que ha ocurrido con esta
guerra y en eso creo que ahí sí hay una
especie de convivencia entre las grandes
potencias es que nos retrotraen por un
poco al orden al orden de la Guerra Fría
o sea Perdón no hablaron de la Guerra
Fría al orden de un orden geopolítico y
es volver a poner la geopolítica como
elemento estructurador de la vida
mundial claro y en ese sentido estamos
en un proceso de inclusión y en eso creo
que los norteamericanos como los
europeos y los rusos están de acuerdo
porque eso es lo que le garantiza a
ellos el poder ellos no tienen los
grandes problemas del mundo de hoy sí
Gonzalo continuó con usted de avanzo con
otro tema le doy minutos para que pueda
opinar sobre este tema pero quiero
preguntarle en ese orden de ideas de de
la diplomacia y de una mesa de diálogo
Turquía se mostraba como el gran país
garante para fomentar este diálogo ahora
con todos los hechos que están
sucediendo internamente en ese país a
raíz del terremoto de la destrucción que
hay y las elecciones presidenciales que
están ya a la vuelta de la esquina y hay
una campaña muy intensa porque erdogan
quiere mantenerse en el poder Turquía
puede seguir siendo visto como ese país
que fomente el diálogo la diplomacia
entre las partes
Bueno yo creo que por un lado como bien
viene siendo cuestionado muy muy
fuertemente hacia adentro de la misma
Turquía por el terremoto por supuesto
una tragedia de magnitudes realmente
impresionante pero más allá de eso
también por distintos hechos de
corrupción por su Estilo de manejo del
poder bastante Si se quiere autoritario
o autocrático cuanto menos viene siendo
cuestionado por una diversa cantidad de
factores Más allá de esto creo que
Turquía tampoco en su momento pudo ser
un un mediador legitimado por la
comunidad internacional y podría hacerlo
hoy en este conflicto también porque si
bien tiene un diálogo fluido con Rusia a
su vez tiene un diálogo fluido con los
países
occidentales bueno por supuesto dentro
de la otan pero de todas maneras se lo
sigue viendo sus mismos socios lo siguen
viviendo como un país bastante cercano
en muchos aspectos sobre por por erdogan
con Putin que tienen una sintonía que
claramente ha sido demostrada a lo largo
a lo largo de los años entonces yo creo
que por eso también no tiene legitimidad
y además Más allá de eso creo que hoy
ningún país podría mediar efectivamente
entre el kremlin y el gobierno de
Ucrania justamente porque no se ha
negado también de manera terminante a
esto y ha dicho macron le he dicho a
biden y le he dicho a sunat como
decíamos hace hace un rato que de
ninguna manera Hay que creerle ni una
sola palabra a a todo lo que diga Putin
y lo único que le pide a los países de
de la otan es ayuda militar envío de
tanques
de ayuda también económica no entonces
tanto Ucrania como Rusia hoy parecen
decididos completamente a continuar el
enfrentamiento bélico un enfrentamiento
bélico que te parece mucho Obviamente
con todas las particularidades del siglo
XXI mucho a un conflicto militar
del siglo 20 sobre todo los pequeños
conflictos territoriales que se daban en
la previa a la a la Primera Guerra a la
Primera Guerra Mundial no donde estos
conflicto de
territorio pero también de como como
decíamos antes de disputar lo que
debería ser para Rusia y para los países
de la otan por el otro lado para el
llamado occidente Sí el nuevo orden
global o el nuevo orden internacional
Gonzalo y en ese en esos términos de un
nuevo orden Pero uno muchas cosas que
han cambiado en a lo largo de este año y
es por ejemplo bueno Turquía es un país
mediador vemos a un bloque cerrado de
los tres países bálticos contra Rusia
apoyando completamente a Ucrania vemos a
Suecia a Finlandia rompiendo sus años de
neutralidad tratando de incorporarse a
la otra pero dependiendo de la decisión
de Turquía que es el país que está
abogando por la diplomacia y por el
diálogo pero le Cierra la puerta a los
otros dos países y vemos también un
cambio en la posición de Alemania que
ahora tiene que aumentar su inversión en
en términos militares para poder hacer
frente a las amenazas que está viviendo
el mundo en la actualidad y también
enviando tanques a la zona de conflicto
algo que le costó mucho Alemania decidir
en a raíz de la historia Pues que hay
con este país sobre todo en la Segunda
Guerra Mundial esto también son indicios
de un nuevo orden dentro de por lo menos
dentro del continente europeo como lo
analiza usted
Sí eso lo que quiero
resquebrajamiento también que se está
dando hacia adentro mismo de los países
de la Unión Europea de los países de la
otan que en un contexto de crisis
económica en un contexto de crisis
energética en un contexto inflacionario
están a su vez cuestionando Por qué sus
gobiernos están ayudando a Ucrania en un
conflicto que muchas veces muchos de los
ciudadanos lo ven como un conflicto
ajeno también no Entonces esto también
claramente va a ir moldeando hay que hay
que recordar que previo a la pandemia ya
los movimientos extremistas de de
ultraderecha los ultranacionalismo estos
populismos ya estaban surgiendo ya
estaban en alza no Y que ahora
posteriormente a la pandemia y durante y
posteriormente a la guerra estos
movimientos también están adquiriendo
nuevas fuerzas gobiernan en Italia
gobiernan en Hungría Son muy fuertes en
la oposición en Francia se están
haciendo fuertes en la oposición en
Alemania Y estos movimientos hoy dicen
Por qué tenemos que ayudar a Ucrania una
guerra que nuestra no Entonces eso
también va generando ricidencias dentro
de los países Hugo en para analizar
también muy rápidamente porque ya me
quedan pocos minutos pero quiero conocer
su opinión en torno a la campaña de
propaganda por ambas partes esta también
ha sido una guerra que ha sido la reina
de la desinformación en redes sociales y
en los medios de comunicación y se le ha
dado mucho peso a un lado o al otro
dependiendo del bando donde uno donde
uno está consultando la información Pero
ha habido muchísimas campañas de
desinformación esto es un nuevo frente
de batalla como lo analiza usted
se ha dicho mucho que de que esto es una
dimensión clave de esta guerra y que la
desinformación es prácticamente un
componente más de este conflicto y es
cierto yo creo que hay una de las cosas
difíciles que cuesta mucho hacer esa vez
encontrar información información de
primera mano
acceder por ejemplo a Fuentes rusas hoy
día resulta bastante complejo
muchas veces uno trata de abrir algunas
páginas y Simplemente no abre decir hay
una hay una serie de limitaciones y
todos tenemos unas una unas visiones muy
sesgada por todos los medios no tenemos
unos medios que son Pro uno so Pro otros
los menos pero todos toman alguna
posición Pero lo que yo diría esa es una
dimensión que me preocupa yo quisiera
rematar lo mío diciendo dos cositas muy
pequeñas adelante pero muy puntual por
favor porque me quedan pocos minutos
una cosa es yo sí creo que empieza a ver
un cansancio en la guerra recientemente
había una encuesta que apareció hoy El
Limón mostrando como en los países
europeos ya empiezan a cantarse de la
guerra y Esta es una cosa que va a venir
en
Estados Unidos cada vez hay más voces
que empiezan también a decir esto no
podemos estar financiando Eternamente
esto también va a tener que tener algún
momento
ahí vemos que hay unos límites Rusia
tiene por sus límites tampoco tiene una
economía tan brillante como para poder
tener una guerra Sí yo creo que van a
haber unas condiciones naturales que van
a llevar a esto Ahora la solución de
esto obviamente no va a venir de los
actores directamente implicados ni
podemos esperarlo ni de excelencia Yo
creo que tiene que haber otro tipo de
países que busquen generar esos Marcos
de diplomacia Y eso no veo prácticamente
desde el sur ahí Brasil países como la
India países como Turquía que sean los
países que en alguna medida vayan
generando o orquestando una posición
mancomunada para llevar a las distintas
fuerzas hacia el diálogo
pasó a preguntarle a Gonzalo ya un par
de preguntas para el cierre del programa
Y es de lo que va a venir para este
conflicto pronto muy puntual Gonzalo
este conflicto entonces termina y pasa
la solución por una incorporación rápida
Express de Ucrania a la Unión Europea
con un estatus especial Porque
claramente nos reúnen las condiciones
que requiere la Unión Europea para para
incorporar a este país o esto se va a
volver una guerra como la de Siria que
es una guerra abierta Lleva más de 10
años que tiene sus altos y sus bajos
pero que nunca concluyó
Bueno hoy es muy difícil saberlo por
supuesto estaríamos siendo demasiada
futurología no pero son dos escenarios
muy probables por un lado el ingreso de
Ucrania contrato especial gobierno
europea por otro lado una una guerra
larga y empantanada
Creo que no va a suceder probablemente
Ucrania ingrese la Unión Europea pero
tampoco eso es necesariamente garantía
de que Rusia va a Cesar su pretensiones
sobre el don vaso sobre el este es muy
difícil ver hoy efectivamente De qué
manera y cómo va a terminar la guerra
con una solución que contente a ambas
partes y por eso es
Lamentablemente están tentadora a hablar
sin temor a equivocarse que vamos a
tener una guerra a mediano plazo No es
cierto Entonces por lo menos durante
todo este año Entonces eso hace pensar
que hoy no no no hay soluciones claras
y Hugo su opinión aunque ustedes nos ha
contado y nos ha dicho un poco lo que
usted ve a futuro pero usted qué piensa
de estas dos posibilidades una guerra
larga o una guerra que pasa por una
incorporación yo creo que va a ser una
guerra larga ahora con respecto al tema
de la incorporación yo creo que ese es
un gran tema para debatirse dentro de la
Unión Europea porque hoy día todo el
mundo es muy pero ucraniano pero yo no
sé qué piensen los europeos cuando
Ucrania más Polonia se conviertan en la
fuerza de prácticamente hegemónica
dentro de la Unión Europea porque
pasarían a tener una vocería
impresionante dentro del concierto
europeo no sé yo dejo abierto eso como
un interrogante porque también en la
parte más occidental de Europa Hay
ciertos recelos a como ven el proceso de
integración europeo los países del este
con los cuales hay enorme creencias con
Hungría con Colonia
o en Bulgaria etcétera entonces yo creo
que esa europea no la veo tan Clara no
me atrevo aquí a decir que va a ocurrir
pero yo no la veo tan Sí y generaría
mucha controversia con otros países que
también son candidatos que incluso ya
tienen estatus un poco más arriba en esa
en esa línea de ascenso hacia la
membresía Como por ejemplo Serbia países
que llevan años esperando una
negociación como Turquía que la tienen
pausa a otros países como Georgia o
Armenia que han mostrado su interés y
otros países de los balcanes y ver una
incorporación Express pues claramente se
le mandaría un mensaje equivocado a
estas naciones aunque se entiende el
escenario en el que se encuentra Ucrania
en este momento a Hugo y a Gonzalo les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en el debate de France 24
haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de France 24 en América Latina
es todo por hoy En nombre del equipo
técnico Les agradecemos su sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera siga con la programación de
France 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]